it's great to be joined today by Ross
Clark who's a columnist and a leader
writer on The Spectator also author of
the war against cash the plot to empty
your wallet and own your financial
future and why you must fight it Ross
I'm very interested in this topic I was
recently in Europe in Denmark I don't
believe that I touched local currency at
any point because the country has
essentially gone completely cashless if
not by default sort of de facto in a
sense let's first talk about why there
has been this move in many parts of the
world and then maybe we'll get into some
of the concerns about it what's
attractive about going cashless um what
from our point of view or from the
financial organization's point of view
or government's point of view yeah I
mean certainly not your it sounds like
you're not in favor of it so what would
be attractive to those who find it
attractive I guess um well I people it's
easy in some ways just to go around
tapping a card against a little card
reader and not fumble around with um
cash that that may be an advantage but
um I'm not against um electronic means
of payment I mean when we're making that
choice to use it that that's absolutely
fine by me and obviously if we're you
know buying stuff over a distance
something we need to do it in some
electronic form if I order a book from
Amazon or something I can't sort of get
the cash to them immediately so I don't
have a problem with electronic forms of
payment that the problem is when it
becomes compulsory when cash and
businesses governments and so on try to
squeeze cash out of use doing away
effectively with the competition that is
offered by using cash I'm going to turn
your question around a little I mean
what is attractive about using cash well
it's free when you and I can do business
with cash we don't have to go through a
middleman we don't have to pay anybody
don't have a bit of our transaction
creamed off by the payments industry and
you've only got to ask yourself what's
in it for the payments industry well an
awful lot um at the moment the the
payments industry is extracting 1
trillion pounds a year from us um by
2020 they reckon that will climb to 2
trillion pounds that is the value of the
cashless society to the payments
industry and that that's just from fees
the the other area which the payments
industry helps to cash in on the
cashless society that's and move it or
not um is through collection and the
sale of data on our spending habits you
know what when we go down to local store
and buy a coffee or something with cash
there's no record of that we could be
anybody buying it but you use your
contactless card your credit card or
some kind of electronic means of payment
and that is registered it creates a
little bit of data a little critten a
little bit of a pattern of your spending
habits and that is extremely valuable
data to marketing firms because then
they know what we're buying they know
the sort of stuff we'd like to buy they
can target us with advertising special
offers and and all the rest and you know
a large part of this move towards the
cashless society is being driven by that
industry by the data intelligence
industry if you like
so let's adapt to that momentarily I
mean to go back to the first part it's
important for people to understand that
even if to the end-user you say well I
either pay ten dollars in cash or ten
dollars with a credit card it's sort of
the exact same cost to me it's important
to understand that for every transaction
the business is paying a fee to the
merchant bank payment processing gateway
at some point if we move completely off
of cash those fees are going to be
priced into what you pay for products in
other words the business is going to
make a decision as to whether they want
to take a loss as a result of accepting
digital payments or whether they just
want to pass on those payments to the
consumer I think most will do the latter
and then at the macro level you
individually might put ten bucks on your
credit card and then pay it off within
30 days and not pay any interest but in
total we know that people carry balances
and not only does the merchant collect a
transaction fee then they collect
interest on the balances that people
carry so for them it's a it's a huge
boon at the beginning and at the tail
end of the transaction yes under direct
fees as well I mean not if in Britain
you buy something with your debit card
or credit card and perhaps in America as
well there is no direct fee but in many
countries there is an Australia for
example you use a contactless card you
will pay a direct fee an extra 1/2
percent or something like that and if
you use your debit card abroad I mean I
was in Russia last week I paid a hotel
bill for two hundred pound was around
two hundred pound and the card company
charged me nearly ten pound to process
that payment I mean that that's that's
quite a lot of money went in wherever
ever I go abroad now III you know take
the cash with me or I'll take a large
amount of cash out of a ATM machine as
soon as I arrive in the country well
that allows me to the next thing because
there is a risk to carrying the cash
right and so I have moved significantly
in the direction of planning ahead when
I travel overseas outside of the United
States and figuring out do I really need
to have cash with me because one of the
advantages that seems very real to me
which is worth paying to me one two or
three percent is that if I don't have
cash on me the cash can't be lost or
stolen and if I have a credit card if
the credit card is stolen I just stopped
payments on the credit
there is a program which prevents me
from being ultimately responsible for
payments that somebody else makes would
it be reasonable to say that that's
worth a few percentage points um if you
realize you've lost your card and you
can cancel you're in a position where
you can cancel it instantly that's okay
that will save you but um if you you
lose a contactless card the contactless
cards we now use in Britain um anybody
can make a purchase of up to thirty
pounds with those cards without giving
any ID without putting in a pin without
producing any kind of identification um
you're potentially gonna lose a lot more
if you lose your contactless car than if
you lose an amount of cash or or if it's
stolen I suppose it's possible but don't
I mean again I'm kind of just thinking
of thinking it through with you even if
you don't in my experience even if there
are fraud even if I haven't lost my card
but somehow somebody has you know
digitally forged a copy of my card and
made purchases even after the fact
I've never altom utley been responsible
for a payment they didn't make oh well
banks and payment companies will often
try and wriggle out of reimbursing
people in those situations and it's go I
mean I looked at I looked up some
figures the eye I found a figure and I
did this for the United States and I
also did it for Britain the number of
people percentage of people who had lost
cash in the previous year with the
percentage of people who had fallen
victim to some kind of card fraud either
having their card cloned having it
stolen having it used without permission
and these three people actually
ultimately lost money and there was no
comparison the the the percentage of
people who are losing money through card
fraud is significantly higher than those
who are losing money through cash being
stolen
so did the idea that yes theoretically
um an electronic payment a card payment
is traceable
it doesn't actually mean that police or
any other kind of Authority is actually
tracing that those payments and I don't
know how it works in America but if you
have you've lost money on a card fraud
in Britain you ring up the police they
don't show any interest at all yeah I
agree with that it's I've just never
heard of anybody needing to do that
because they were able to handle it
through through the credit card company
but I think that there's sort of like a
parallel issue here which I am much much
more concerned than some of the other
issues which we've mentioned so far
which is for me moving to cashless
moving to credit payments and and
technology based payments it seems like
it will have a the effect of
significantly increasing inequality and
what what I mean by that is that once
again we will be creating a system
whereby those who are more rural than
urban or suburb and those who may not
have the financial means or credit to
obtain some of these mechanisms will be
sort of further pushed out of certain
elements of the economy and and I think
that that really is a concern I don't
know where you weigh in on that well
that's absolutely true and I mean sort
of moving now to I'm not just sort of
system of card payments there's a lot of
payments industry trying to push us all
towards some paying with our smartphones
well you know if you've got a system
where we have to pay with our
smartphones you will first see well you
need a smart phone you need it to be
fully charged up you need some kind of
internet reception and as you say there
are a lot of rural areas which don't
have good internet coverage its
disadvantage in that the people making
the purchases and also the businesses I
mean hey how do you opera how would you
operate a business in a remote area if
you could only accept payments by um
electronic means and that's what got
smart phone ownership there's a lot of
people find it very very difficult to
use a smart phone um you look at other
bits you know the ownership of smart
phones almost Universal among young
people but in Britain um there's only 18
percent of over 65s actually own a
smartphone um makes it because people
find them very difficult to use they're
very fiddly and if you got arthritis or
suffer from other some other disability
which makes it difficult to use um I
have a daughter who has learning
disability she can handle cash she can
understand cash but to operate a
smartphone and to deal with all those
fiddly sort of apps programs whatever
you want to call them that's extremely
difficult for she's she's not going to
be able to do that and um q exactly sort
of person who will be disempowered um
through a cashless society and
governments payments industry seem quite
happy to push this drive to cashless
payments without actually considering
people like that at all thinking out
loud and this is speculative of course
are we better off trying to figure out
how to solve some of the problems you
just pointed out if we accept that there
is a certain inevitability here because
I'm sort of reminded of you know when
there was this argument made that we
really should push back against the
development of motor vehicles because
the horse buggy drivers are going to go
out of business and thinking now that
that might have actually prevented the
development of the modern automobile it
seems completely inconceivable is there
some element of inevitability here no I
think motor cars are very interesting
parallel really because you go back to
the sort of 1960s and we had sort of
predictions that you know all households
would have a motor car by 1985 therefore
we should design all our cities around
the motorcar and never mind pedestrians
cyclists they won't exist in the future
because everybody will be going by owned
by car
um well certainly in Britain car
ownership has never exceeded more than
about 70 percent of households and
that's actually falling now um you know
it's quite clicking cars motor cars
aren't gonna go away they're far too
useful for that but
you know there's no need to try to a
little bit was it a very silly idea to
try to eliminate pedestrians eliminate
cyclists from our cities because you
know give people the choice of how to
move around and you know we now know for
the environmentally point at the point
of view is extremely good thing that
people walk and cycle around and I think
you know we're in that position now with
cash and electronic payments we're at
that position as we were with cars in
the 1960s when companies and businesses
governments are saying oh we won't need
cash in future because everybody will
pay to have everything electronically
you know I that should not be allowed to
happen we you know in 3040 years time I
predict we will still be using cash in
for some forms of payment because it is
very convenient it's some cheap it's
free to use and for yeah and because it
some gives the the poor the people with
disabilities it gives them a means of
taking part in the economy which would
be very hard to achieve through purely
electronic means all right I don't
pretend to know what we will be doing in
40 years but I I'm curious to know
that's for sure we've been speaking with
Ross Clark columnist and also writer on
the spectator the book is war against
cash the plot to empty your wallet and
own your financial future and why you
must fight it I really appreciate you
sharing your point of view today thank
you